ce sont des travailleurs qui se
décrivent comme essentielle mais qui se
font souvent dans le paysage urbain
voilà que ces livreurs ne veulent plus
rester dans l'ombre ça commence c'est le
cas de brice offert qui travaille pour
gamers united un syndicat de livreurs
récemment constitué à toronto
normalement je sors quatre ou cinq jours
par semaine
j'ai deux professions bresse a commencé
à faire des livraisons à vélo en 2015
depuis la pandémie c'est devenu sa
principale source de revenus on veut
être reconnu comme des employés parce
que ces compagnies ils ont le contrôle
complet sur la façon dont on travaille
[Musique]
le travail est éreintant et les
conditions difficiles de sécurité
d'emploi de salaire minimum davantage
sociaux car livreur comme lui sont
considérés comme des travailleurs
autonomes et non comme des employés
à cela s'ajoute le fait que beaucoup de
ces livreurs sont de nouveaux arrivants
qui n'ont pas nécessairement accès à
d'autres types d'emplois c'est le cas de
suraj sharma qui est récemment arrivé
d'inde avocat de formation il doit se
tourner vers hubert pour payer ses
factures en attendant que ses diplômes
soient reconnus au canada
80% des personnes qui ont cet emploi
sont de nouveaux arrivants à ferme le
livreur qui voudrait que le gouvernement
protège mieux les travailleurs comme lui
pendant la pandémie le gouvernement
faute a souvent souligné l'apport de ces
travailleurs
ils ministre ontarien du travail répète
qu'une réforme des lois encadrant le
travail précaire sera bientôt présenté
on est dans le noir devant cette main
tendue bresso faire reste méfiant et
s'inquiètent que nouveau cadre
législatif dans la province ne soit
al'avantage des multinationales comme
hubert il faut être réaliste que
beaucoup des politiciens beaucoup des
gens d'un gouvernement leur campagne
sont supportés par les gens avec
l'argent
l'an dernier ces compagnies ont remporté
une victoire légal de ta et un
californie qui a cimenté le statut de
travailleur autonome de leurs livreurs
ces syndicalistes américains rappellent
qu hubert a dépensé des millions en
lobbying pour parvenir à cette fin et
croit que l'entreprise utilise les mêmes
tactiques au nord de la frontière
au canada hubert ne cache pas ses
efforts de lobbying l'entreprise de
mettre de l'avant un modèle hybride où
ces travailleurs ne seraient pas
reconnus comme des employés mais
obtiendrait des avantages sociaux à la
pièce ont créé un fonds qui serait gérée
par l'industrie et les travailleurs aux
autres pourraient utiliser ce
fondamental sociaux comme il le souhaite
entre 2005 et 2016 la proportion de
travailleurs à la demande au canada est
passé de 5,5 à 8,2 pour cent
les surfeurs quoique ce chiffre
continuera d'augmenter d'où l'importance
pour ces travailleurs de se mobiliser
pourquoi est ce que je pourrai pas
gagner ma vie à faire ce travail tout le
monde devrait avoir droit à la dignité
travailler dans la dignité c'est le
combat que brees soffer a choisi de
mener il promet de continuer la lutte
qu'elles portent les obstacles sur son
chemin
s'il m'était radio canada toronto